i want to bring in a couple of brothers
who i got so much love for and that is
jim trotter and
both long time nfl reporters look at
these dudes these guys know the nfl
inside and out but more important throw
up the picture of their new podcast it's
called huddle and flow
okay
and on this podcast
who came up with the title
was it trotter
or what let me kill you with the title
there you go there you go there it is i
want y'all to see look at his artwork
look at this if that ain't pimping that
is befitting of jim trotter and steve
white's right right there they bring 40
plus years of combined experience and
they got unfiltered entertaining
conversations about issues on and off
the field and they discuss the hbcu
experience both then and now and the
significance of of hbcus and their
contributions to sports and society so
let's just start there i'll start that
with you to try um
billy d williams voice of yours man it's
good to talk to you just just kind of
speak to the significance first and
foremost of of howard university in your
life in your career
oh i don't think we have enough time to
speak to the significance in in my life
and my career um you have to remember i
grew up going to predominantly white
high school
in white high school's period or schools
period i'm sorry
and once i got to howard it was um
i can't even begin to put into words i
just felt at home you know i was at a
place where i felt like i was more than
a number
that the expectations for me were such
that i was going to succeed it was a
nurturing atmosphere
and i loved it and i can say to this day
having graduated in 1986 that if i were
to do it all over again
i would be right back there
steve you feel the same way
yeah look and i had the experience of
going to a pwi you know predominantly
white institution for two years i went
to university of missouri to play
football
and really felt isolated you know and i
grew up like jim in a suburban town
outside of st louis majority uh white
students never had i think but one or
two black teachers my entire career
before i got to college so i transferred
to howard and immediately it was like
whoa
okay i'm not over here i don't have to
go to the two fraternity parties every
week to be with black people and so
it was really
you know
the the competition what i'll say this
howard will bring out the competition
everything to how you dress to go to
class
bike was just talking about
to to pushing you in school so i
transferred in right as jim and kamala
were transferring out you know i was
there with gus johnson and stan veret
and fredricka whitfield and michelle
miller i mean jim will tell you i'm sure
his class was just as strong that
cluster
so we were all driven competitively in
so many different ways i think that's
where the carryover into real life
really happened for me
tell me tell me about the uh the podcast
i mean it's like it's a great it's a
great title neither one of you came up
with the title so i need to know who
came up with it
and
and just what what you are looking or
what you are looking uh to get out of it
well our producer one of our
co-producers thomas warren came up with
the name and he's a howard man as well
and
we were thinking about all sorts of
names something and steve came up with
something like we we got issues
and i love that but others thought no
it's a little too confrontational or the
connotations aren't what you might want
um but really all it is guys
it's like you and i sitting down having
a conversation and we come from a
perspective that's different from some
of our colleagues
our white colleagues and so steve and i
when i first got to nfl network we
talked about doing a podcast and
we're now in a climate where um the
league felt comfortable allowing us to
do this this podcast and
i couldn't be happier about it because
you know steve brings a certain
experience life experience i bring a
life experience and we just sit down and
we talk about what's going on and it's
not just football it's life it's family
it's television whatever
and guys the one thing about that's
really cool when jim talked about we've
been trying to do this for two years
i mean all honesty we first proposed it
we were laughed out of the room
we were we were made to feel like we
wasted somebody's time
and so
now in this climate
when a lot of people want to pat
themselves on the back for being woke
and coming up with initiatives that
represent
it was brought back to us so jim and i
were like however we get it we're gonna
make it real we're gonna make it
important we're gonna give voices to
people who have not had them we will
take on the nfl even though our
employers those are the first three
letters of our employer's name we
challenge them we have people on
challenging some of the
perfecting machine
that they're coming up with like lift
every voice and saying that's nobody
asked for that right so we have
discussions talking about this with
sports people with non-sports people
and i got to say this about my guy jim
trotter and and you guys know this well
his ability to draw information
out of people casual conversation is
uncanny uh we just had a great
conversation with doug williams on hbcus
and what deion sanders is going to face
in jackson state
and with larry fitzgerald and what jim
was able to really pull
out of this everybody should hear so
look it's a go-to
same type of sports guy podcast it's
absolutely don't let steve for y'all man
steve is bringing it out too
trust me on that look
hey listen you know i got love for both
you brothers both y'all have looked out
for me and i have modeled a lot of my
game i i started out as a nfl reporter
and trust me i was joined at the hip
with jim trotter uh and saying y'all
don't wait
y'all don't know i remember first time i
ever saw michael smith
i'm at a raiders press conference in
alameda
and this young brother is sort of in the
back of the room and he's standing up
while everyone else is kind of fidgeting
about what questions do they want to ask
or should i ask this and mike's just
like
what about this
what about this
and i was like this brother's gonna be
all right you know
didn't know
he was back in boston at the globe and i
was like yeah he gonna be all right and
look at him now he's here with michael
holly and they both bring a game
i'm proud of you both absolutely
appreciate you and steve everything you
just said about how i was received two
years ago
you could take that and insert michael
and i story it's the same story man so
you are definitely preaching to our our
souls right there and by the way why are
we showing love a lot of people don't
realize this the conversation around
colin kaepernick
is so
mainstream if you will or so universally
accepted and was so far removed from his
original protest people don't remember
that steve weiss is the person who first
asked colin kaepernick first asked colin
kaepernick why were you sitting for the
national anthem and the rest is history
that's a steve white story just in case
y'all didn't know where this entire
conversation started at least a modern
version of it it started with steve
weiss um i want to ask though just about
you so you say you talked to dion i'll
see you talk to doug williams about dion
taking the gig uh at jackson state steve
for those of us who haven't had a chance
to listen to the podcast yet and again
you can find on apple podcast um what
did doug have to say be a grambling
state alum a former gremlin state coach
and most people know him as the first
black quarterback to win the super bowl
with the washington football team back
in 87 88 what did he have to say about
dion going to jackson state
well jim and i couldn't get dion because
he's got another podcast obligation so
he can't go on other people's podcast
um jim thought it was it was a pro jim
and i thought it was supposed to have
doug because doug has been
right doug was a household name he
started coaching at morehouse
no coaching traveling but we talked
about some of the things that dion bring
the ability to recruit the ability to
cross fine
um the ability to bring
that rarely is remember this is book
that produced glen barney and walter
payton and schools like that but also
doug had the great perspective of
fundraising at hbcus it's very difficult
because hbcus when people give money
they often you won't let you ear market
for an athletic program or a particular
sport or whatever so doug was just
fantastic
talking about that but guy who's also
very good doug is on several committees
working with the nfl to increase
diversity among coaching and general
manager hires and he was
exceptional talking about that because
remember most hbcus are not going to
play into the spring
when it comes to football there's only
one player from an hbcu drafted last
year now they're going to be behind the
eight ball in terms of drafting players
so doug's on a committee to bring
awareness to some of these draft
eligible players so it's really
wide-ranging and a dense
uh solution but we did come up with the
best answer on how owners
can meet general manager and coaching
candidates and you guys can come wait
now
we're having a cookout
at doug williams house in dc
yeah he said his wife is gonna make
gumbo
i love it
but we're gonna bring all of you all
this in
listen a cookout a cookout hold on y'all
got a date y'all got a date yet i was
gonna say what is it
juneteenth maybe juneteenth weekend of
course naturally yes absolutely yes
that's what we spent in june
we're going to say no
to a cookout
on juneteenth
at doug's house
knowing that
you do say no we're gonna put it out
there
exactly they get they get the
credibility i'm invited to the cookout
they get that out of it you know
i got a couple things for you uh you
know why uh said something a few minutes
ago
that and it takes us takes me back to
our first show our first show we were
talking about lift every voice and sing
which is such a powerful song for me and
my entire family
that i said i said in our first show i'm
not ready to share that
i'm not ready to share that with the
nation especially
when it's going to be pulled and tugged
in this uh often uh contentious and very
silly
uh political fight you feel that way how
do you feel about steve and how do you
feel about it jim because i i'm holding
on to lift every voice and sing i don't
want to share with anybody
it's not a matter of not sharing i mean
i'm all about educating those who want
to be educated and whatnot it was when
we're talking about police officers not
being held accountable
for shooting and killing unarmed black
men and women
i don't need to hear
the black national anthem or something
that i grew up in church singing or
something that my family passed i want
to hear
legislators talking about changing the
laws that allow these type
transgressions to continue i don't give
a damn about this
in empty stadiums you're playing it
i mean that's just a backpacking to me
it's something like people patting
themselves in the back like look at this
marketing gesture we came out with
aren't we woke now
but that's my point i don't know what
that's that's what i mean but i don't
want it to be and what you're saying is
right a hundred percent
i don't want it to be caught up in like
some marketing uh some stick it's it's
much more than sick to me so put that
aside and as you said you know get to
the substantive issues how do you feel
about it trotter
no i feel exactly the same look we have
to remember it was only a year ago where
the commissioner of the nfl said we have
moved on
we have moved beyond all of this
and now what do we have
we have hashtags we have in racism in
the end zones we have the names of
social justice victims on the back of
helmets we have psas
and then we have lift every voice and
thing being played prior to the national
anthem it's like the league is trying
too hard to prove
that somehow it is woke and aware
as antoine bolden said on our podcast
regarding the fight for social justice
just do the work
the rest will take care of itself and
unfortunately as you guys know the nfl
is always reactionary instead of being
proactive
stop trying to get people to pat you on
the back and and show that you're woke
and committed to your players just do
the work and the rest will speak for
itself
and meanwhile that same nfl is using a
racist standard to deny players former
players uh claims you know for that
suffer from dementia suffer from from
brain trauma using a racist standard to
to reject their uh their claims there um
i know you guys got to go
to
did you did you or anyone else who has
followed the nfl for all of these years
think
that this cte settlement
was going to resolve all of this
because i know i didn't
yeah
no i i i'm sorry
i lost you what would you say
no no
can you hear me mike smith i can hear
you i can hear you now jim i'm sorry i
was having audio issues would you say i
missed you
no i was just saying that did anyone
really believe that the cte settlement
was going to settle this issue
because there are a lot of folks i've
been told even back in the beginning
that all of these these review processes
were going to be dragged out and as
morbid as this may sound
hoping that some of these players would
pass away and the families would never
see that money so i'm not surprised that
there are these standards out there that
are now inhibiting
a retired player's ability to get money
yeah no question no question yeah sorry
about that man my audio went out dropped
off for a second so thank you for
for uh for that point listen you guys
were nice enough to take time out of
your busy day y'all got another
news breaking interview that you guys
got to get to before we go i got one
last thing actually i got two things for
you one can we please please please do
this again and by again i mean regularly
okay i want to do more of this with you
guys but two
real quick you mentioned doug williams a
couple years ago the undefeated put out
a list of the best hbcu athletes they
had doug williams at the top obviously
you know great performances of both 22.
crazy yeah but that's christopher's
performance nonetheless i'll let him
live so you first then trotter your
greatest hbcu athlete i know that's
putting you on the spot but greatest
hbcu athlete of all time
oh man it's either to me either wilma
rudolph or walter pate
okay
i like it
i mean i i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
argue with wilma but i'm gonna go the
other way in football and say jerry
right
all right he's the goal for real
yep so we got tennessee state uh we got
jackson state representative and we got
mississippi valley state representative
and h.u the pride of hu steve weiss jim
trotter
huddle and flo is the podcast
love y'all man thank you all so much for
falling through appreciate other
brothers
appreciate y'all